You know gravity as the force that keeps us
from falling off this planet. But it's so
much more than that. Gravity predicts the
formation of planets, explains why they are
spherical and why the orbits of planets around
the sun are elliptical. It helped us discover
one of the planets in our own solar system,
and the formation of Saturn’s rings. Gravity
can bend and even trap light, and it governs
some of the behavior of the universe itself.
In this video, we’ll look at the different
models of gravity and explore how each helps
us understand these diverse phenomena.
This video is part of the Governing Rules
video series. A small number of rules describe
the physical and chemical interactions that
are possible in our universe.
Hello. My name is Nergis Mavalvala. I am a
professor in the physics department at MIT,
and today I'll be talking with you about gravity.
After watching this video, you should be able
to recognize several different expressions
for gravity, and to analyze situations involving
gravity in preparation for problem-solving.
We also hope that you gain an appreciation
for the universal nature of gravity and the
many places its effects can be seen.
There are three expressions of gravity that
scientists find useful. We're going to talk
about all three of them today: gravity near
the earth's surface, Newton's universal law
of gravity, and Einstein's gravitational field
equations, which are the core of general relativity.
We'll be spending most of our time with the
second one, but we're going to start with
the simplest item and build upward and outward
from there. You should make sure that the
first two equations are in your notes.
Let's start with the basics: gravity near
Earth's surface. In studying Newton's Laws
we all learn that F = ma. Near Earth's surface,
that "a," acceleration, is provided by Earth's
gravity. The value is almost constant, so
we use this small "g" constant to represent
it.
We're all familiar with the most basic applications
of gravity - that we stay on the ground, that
objects fall downward, that we have to work
harder walking up a hill than down.
There are also many applications of gravity
that are hidden from us in our day-to-day
experience. For instance, elevators use counterweights
to ease the load on the motor. As gravity
pulls on the counterweight, the tension it
puts on the cable pulls the elevator upward
and helps to balance the force of gravity
on the elevator itself.
Some older mountain railways also use counterbalancing,
with one train car moving upward as the other
moves down.
Pile drivers are construction machines that
rely on the pull of gravity to slam large
weights into the ground, digging holes and
driving foundations for buildings.
As useful as this simple view of gravity is,
it's fairly limited - it can't explain why
the planets are spherical instead of, say,
cube-shaped. It also can't explain the orbits
of the planets, or the action of the tides.
Let's move to a more complex expression for
gravity that can help us understand these
things.
Newton's law of universal gravitation is a
powerful model that can explain many different
phenomena. Let's dive right in.
Unlike the most basic view of gravity, in
which it pulls straight down, leaving Canadians
to wonder why penguins don't fall off the
planet, Newton's gravity shows that all objects
are pulled toward each other's centers. Thus,
we all stay firmly planted on Earth's surface.
Because the gravitational force pulls equally
in all directions, large bodies in space tend
to be spherical. The Sun, all planets, and
even larger moons tend towards a spherical
shape for this reason.
Newton's law of gravity also means that all
objects are pulled toward each other, such
as planets toward the sun. By solving the
differential equations that come from this
law, we can obtain the elliptical orbits that
all planets have as they move around their
stars.
We can get all sorts of ellipses, from the
near-circles we see in the inner planets,
to Pluto's elongated orbit, to comets that
swing far out of the solar system.
The smaller pulls that planets have toward
each other can be useful too. They're what
allowed us to discover Neptune, by looking
at the disturbances in the orbit of Uranus.
Newton's law of gravity also gave us new insight
into events on Earth, like our tides. Objects
on one side of the Earth are pulled more strongly
toward the moon than objects on the other
side, in a phenomenon called tidal forces.
Our own galaxy, the Milky Way, has gravitational
interactions with other smaller galaxies nearby.
Its disc-like shape and spiral arms may have
come from tearing those galaxies apart.
We see other galaxies colliding in many other
places in the universe, as gravity pulls them
together. It actually seems to be fairly common.
Speaking of galaxies, Newton's law also tells
us how fast galaxies should rotate. We can
predict a particular A curve for how fast
the stars will be moving according to their
distance from the center - that's curve A
here. But when we measure the actual velocity
of those stars, we get B curve B instead.
This was our first indication of the existence
of dark matter - some sort of substance that
produces gravity but doesn't interact with
light. We couldn't see it, but we could see
its effects. Dark matter surrounds and is
part of every galaxy. In fact, there's so
much that it makes up most of the galaxy!
Physicists are still trying to figure out
what this dark matter might be.
We can also use Newton's law of gravity to
look beyond the structure of individual galaxies
- we can look at clusters of galaxies, superclusters,
and even the entire visible universe.
Fair enough.
When we do look at things on that scale, where
individual galaxies become just dots, we can
see massive structures of galaxies, like this
Great Wall here, or these empty intergalactic
voids.
In recent years supercomputers have become
powerful enough to simulate the formation
of such structures in our universe. Here you
can see the result of one such simulation,
with each speck of light representing a galaxy
worth of stars or dark matter. Using Newton's
law of gravity, superclusters of galaxies
and intergalactic voids appear naturally!
A real triumph of Newton's approach was that
it worked for everything from people on Earth
out to some of the most distant objects we
can see.
But it couldn't handle everything, and that's
why we need this next part.
The most powerful model of gravity is described
by Einstein's field equations, which are the
core of general relativity. This equation
may not make sense to you now, but later in
your career you may learn about something
called tensors, which are related to vectors.
In this equation, tensors describe the gravitational
effects of both matter and energy on all
things around them. This equation is very
hard to solve, even for experts. Some of the
cases we know how to solve tell us about black
holes and gravitational lensing, and give
us insight into the universe when it was very young.
Black holes were one of the first solutions
to Einstein's field equations. You've probably
heard of black holes, which are objects so
massive that they warp space and time, and
even light cannot escape their gravitational pull.
At the center of our galaxy, and of many large
galaxies, are supermassive black holes. We
can see their effects as stars near the center
of the galaxy whip around them at high speed.
While black holes trap light, other massive
objects can have an effect too. Light bends
in its path as it moves past heavy objects
like stars.
This can lead to gravitational lensing, in
which light from a distant object is bent
around both sides of a heavy object. This
lets us see multiple views of an object, or
even warped images.
Einstein's field equations also include this
lambda value: the cosmological constant.
This value can be used to describe a universe
that collapses or holds steady, expands slowly,
or expands at an accelerating rate. Astronomers
are working to measure this value, and we
seem to be in the third case - a universe
that expands faster and faster.
Einstein's theory of gravity remains one of
the best-tested and most accurate theories
in all of science. It can explain everything
that Newtonian gravity can and more, things
we wouldn't otherwise be able to predict or
understand, it can even make predictions about how
the universe will end. You can see why people
would be interested in studying it.
These three gravitational equations describe
a huge range of phenomena in our natural world,
from things in our own home to the farthest
objects we can see. I hope that you will be
motivated to learn more about them. Understanding
these laws and being able to use them will
lead you to a greater appreciation of the
natural world.
Now it's time to take some of the examples
we saw and examine them in a different way.
You will need paper and something to write
with for this part of the video.
Knowing that gravity causes a particular phenomenon
is good, but we also want to know how to describe
these phenomena mathematically.
We'll be giving you some situations that can
be described through gravity. Your job, working
in pairs or groups of three, is to determine
what information you would want in order to
solve a particular problem.
For instance, let's say that we drop a rock
and want to know how long it would take to
fall. We would want to know the rock's initial
height and whether air resistance would be
important. We might also want to double-check
the value for gravity on Earth.
That example is pretty simple. Let's do a
more complicated one. Given an asteroid headed
toward Earth, and its velocity and location,
which approach would we need to find out whether
the asteroid will hit the Earth, and if so,
how long it will be before the impact?
To understand an object's trajectory we need
to know about its starting point - the position
of the asteroid as compared to Earth. We also
want to know how fast it's moving and in what
direction. We'll need to know the mass of
the Earth and of the asteroid, because both
will factor into the force applied on the
asteroid.
Some things are arbitrary choices - for instance,
we can pick any coordinate system we like.
Since gravity pulls objects together, we might
want to choose polar coordinates centered
on the Earth to make things easier.
Finally, there are some things that we'll
want to know that are of a more general nature.
For instance, how do we take into account
gravity from the Sun? Can we measure all of
our positions and velocities from the Earth's
reference frame as if it were moving with
constant velocity? Should we track the Earth
as it moves in its orbit?
These are things we might not know when we
start to solve a problem, and it's important
to write them down.
Now it's your turn. We'll put four problems
on the screen. Your instructor will assign
problems to different groups. Each group's
job is to write up a list of what information
you would need in order to solve the problem.
Remember, you don't need to actually solve
it - just write down what you would need to
know in order to find a solution.
Here are the problems. Thank you for watching our video, and good
luck with your class.